&gt;&gt; Instead of choosing those two points, I'm going to choose two other points.
We can see that to go from this point to the second point, we need to rise three
units up and run six units to the right. Because we went up vertically three
units, we know that this is a positive 3. And since we traveled six units to the
right, we know that the run is really positive 6 in the positive direction. When
we find the slope, or the m, we're really finding the ratio of the rise divided
by the run. We already know that 3 6ths is really the same thing as 1 half. This
is great, we got the same slope as from before. We can see that the slope of 3
6ths is the same thing as 1 half. It always puts us on our line. But remember we
can also read slope in other directions. I don't have to start from this point
and go to this point, I could go in the reverse direction. If I started from
this point, 6, 6. I would travel down three units, and then left six units. So
here, the vertical distance is really a drop. It's a 3 unit distance down. So
the rise would be negative 3. We move three units down in a negative direction.
And 6 units left in a negative direction. Since both of these directions are
negative, we know the rise is really negative 3. And the run is really negative
6. A negative divided by a negative makes a positive so we are left with 3 6ths,
or 1 half. That's pretty cool. Any way we try and find the slope, we always get
the same ratio. We just need to be careful about our directions and our negative
signs.